the entire crypto Market is about to
explode here is what you need to do in
April 2024 Bitcoin is going to see a
scarcity event called the Bitcoin
harving at this moment the amount of
Bitcoin the miners receive as
compensation for securing the network is
going to cut in half this happens
roughly every four years and
historically has actually been the start
of an explosive 18month bull market so
if we continue to look at history
Bitcoin is expected to break new time
highs somewhere between Q4 of 2024 and
q1 of 2025 this means you might want to
start considering taking some profit and
actually selling in 18 months from now
the Bitcoin Haring scarcity event is
just a few months away you don't want to
miss the train